what do you think of uh
uh the narratives that women are being
told today things like
um you're beautiful at any size you know
for example that's something that we've
been hearing loud and clear all over
social media lizzo is beautiful she's
absolutely stunning and brave right
um what do you think of those stories
you know those narratives that they can
tell in the gals
dude uh that is detrimental to women
yeah we are told that we are tens no
matter what size shape what we bring to
the table anything and I actually had
this conversation with a friend a couple
weeks ago
um she was a single woman 35 never been
married never had kids and I'm like what
what are you like on a scale of one to
ten where do you put yourself she's like
I'm a 12. I know that I'm a 12 and I
deserve the best
and I was like okay what would you later
uh I would say she's a six she's
probably she could lose some weight
she's adorable and she's sweet but she's
not a 10. and she looks at me and she
goes well what would you rate yourself
and I was like I'm a seven I know I'm a
seven I'm good with the seven like I
don't expect
a man that's here if I'm here right
now does that mean that I'm not worthy
of love no like I know my value I know
who I am and what I am
but I don't know realistic like women
are not realistic and they're fed this
line of [__] that they are perfect
just as they are and they shouldn't do
anything different and they should just
expect Prince Charming to show up
because
so they are you're okay with the notion
that women are Beauty objects to men
uh yeah
so
a lot of women fight with that they were
you know they really struggle with the
notion that women are Beauty objects to
men or beauty objects in general in the
sexual Marketplace some would even say
sex objects to men
well that doesn't mean that's all we are
right but I
but there's so much of our value and
Society even says that like
do you think that that's like the vast
majority of what women are to men Beauty
sex objects because
I would I would argue that you'd have a
difficult time
um
like a guy would never say anything you
know like along the lines of oh she's
got a really nice personality I want to
bang her sort of thing it's like you
know right like you can't bang a nice
personality correct see what I'm saying
so like the vast majority of the
attraction that comes from like it's why
women
you've all got your hair done you got
your makeup on you're looking Wonderful
Tonight perfect right like all of that
work that goes in it like I just put on
a shirt took a shower right so that's
it's similar for a guy but as far as it
goes like are you comfortable with with
the notion the you know the narrative
that I believe is reality anyway where
men are success objects and women are
Beauty objects but women struggle with
that like what do you say to them
but they really struggle with it
I gotta call BS on this really quick
um
so specifically to Leandra because I'm
because I'm I'm aware of you know one of
your businesses and the uh the badass
Boudoir and I'm gonna read this directly
from
the website and I'm curious uh what you
have to say about this
so this is an experience all women need
to have to be reminded that regardless
of what the scale says how many stretch
marks you have your height hit size or
how many chins we think we have we're
badass and beautiful right here in the
body we're in so why not show it off it
sounds a little sounds a little so yes
but let me explain
and you're you're also kind of I mean
you charge people money for these too so
yeah I'm so curious on where let me
explain how this happens okay so I bring
these women in and we do Retreats and it
is centered around Boudoir but that is
mainly like just a catalyst okay we also
have a lot of coaching and conversations
that go into that whole weekend so so
many women are afraid to actually get
naked physically emotionally mentally
all of that and Boudoir is just like the
in for it so I get these women to get
naked and they see themselves through a
different light and then they see their
value in the fact that oh I am hot I am
worth eating right and exercising and
doing better and coming back and doing
this again and being
you know having a better body it's not
just about your body but having this
value of more than just oh I'm a size 12
and that's just who I am no like I try
to push more than just
healthy you disagree with me you just
agreed that women are Beauty objects
I think they are Beauty they are Beauty
objects like we are put in this spot
that also telling women that they're
that they're beautiful regardless like
do you ever reject women that come to
these and say you're not good looking
enough to do this no you need to go work
on yourself but I can tell you that
Boudoir was a catalyst for me like I
didn't find myself sexy whatsoever and
what's the definition of foods I mean
sorry look at these I mean I can see the
women on this bus and I know what you
look like versus what some of these
women look like I mean there's you're
objectively more attractive than
probably 90 of the women I see in this
photo so I mean I think you're already
starting first well when I first did
Boudoir was almost five years ago and I
did not look the way that I do now I did
not take care of my body but because of
that that was the Catalyst for me to
take care of my body to become a bikini
competitor like it showed me the value
of who if we're talking about looks like
who I was just through that lens of
somebody else's View and then I was like
oh [__] uh sorry Clarity please uh
Boudoir what does that mean again so
Boudoir is uh like it's sexy pictures
it's not porn so you take
objectively unattractive women put them
in Nice Clothing good photography and
lighting with motorcycles
and you make them look sexy
it's about angles and I mean there's so
much more to it but yeah isn't that
and then they use these photographs for
what
whatever they want dating apps
um actually but I would say the majority
of the women are married and or have
they're in relationships so they use
them to send to their men or for their
own confidence boost too that's huge but
okay so there's a little bit of a blurry
line there moth you know pointed to it
you know because I was asking you like
you think women are beautiful at any
size is little Hots or anything but on
your website you're basically saying
your stretch marks don't matter I'm
saying that we can find the beauty in
any size but that doesn't mean that's
where you should stay right you should
find the value in yourself to push
towards a better body and a better
health right okay so I'm not saying
we're using the term Beauty really
literally are we I mean if everyone is
beautiful then no one's beautiful but I
mean by itself is a discriminatory
discriminatory term
but there's a scale to Beauty too right
sure yeah it's all physical there's also
a scale to weight as well
and when you apply weight to a scale and
the numbers go up and they get really
high then you should really take that
seriously right right I think all the
women agree here yeah I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out